>> Tucker: IT'S INCREASINGLY
CLEAR THAT CORPORATE AMERICA
IS NOW THE LEFT'S
IDEOLOGICAL ENFORCER, IT
COULDN'T BE CLEARER, IT'S
NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
SILICON VALLEY.
UNTIL THIS WEEK DENNIS
FINDLAY WAS AN EDITOR AT THE
FREE PRESS IN VERMONT.
THE GO
THE GANNETT FIRED HIM.
DENNIS JOINS US TONIGHT TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
DENNIS, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
TO TALK TO YOU I WAS
INSEARLY CONFUSED BY YOUR
FIRING SINCE YOU DIDN'T
ATTACK TRANSGENDERED PEOPLE.
DRIVERS LICENSES FROM THE
TWEETS THAT I SAW.
BUT YOU ASKED QUESTIONS TO
SOMEBODY ELSE ON TWITTER.
YIND HOW THAT WAS OUT OF
OUT OF BOUNDS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T BELIEVE WITH IT.
IT WAS A POWERFUL CONTINGENT
OF SPEECH POLICE OUT THERE
IT WENT ON ALL THROUGH THE
WEEKEND.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO STOP
UNTIL THEY HAD MY HEAD ON
THE PLATTER.
THEY FINALLY DOT IT ON
MONDAY EVENING.
>> Tucker: YOU SAY VERMONT
IS LIBERAL.
THERE IS NOTHING LIBERAL
ABOUT TAKING A MAN'S
LIVELIHOOD AWAY BECAUSE YOU
DISAGREE WITH HIM.
THAT'S NOT LIBERAL.
THEY THINK IT'S A FEATHER IN
THEIR CAP ANY TIME THEY GET
RID OF SOMEBODY WHO
DISAGREES WITH THEM.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE A
JOURNALIST AND HAVE BEEN FOR
A LONG TIME.
WHAT'S TRUE.
THE TRUTH IS A DEFENSE.
>> TRUTH IS A DEFENSE.
YOU GET TO SAY WHAT IS TRUE.
BUT IN THE AGE WE LIVE, IN
OUR COMPANIES LOTTED OF
MEDIA COMPANIES SAY WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE OBJECTIVE,
IMPARTIAL, ET CETERA, ET
CETERA.
I WANT TO ASK QUESTIONS.
THERE A LOT OF THINGS GOING
ON WE HAVE TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT.
PUTTING A THIRD GENDER ON A
DRIVERS LICENSE IS SOMETHING
THAT I THOUGHT WE SHOULD ASK
A QUESTION ABOUT.
>> Tucker: SOMETHING ON
TWITTER SAID I THINK THIS IS
GREAT AND COURAGEOUS AND YOU
SAID WHY IS IT GREAT AND
COURAGEOUS?
>> CORRECT.
AND I REALLY.
I BELIEVE IF I HAD SAID THAT
IS GREAT AND COURAGEOUS.
IF I HAD SAID THAT WE
WOULDN'T BE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY.
>> Tucker: NOT ASKING YOU TO
BE OBJECTIVE THEY ARE ASKING
YOU TO TOE A VERY SPECIFIC
LINE.
>> OF COURSE THEY ARE ASKING
ME TO TOE THE LINE AND AGREE
WITH THEM.
THEY ARE ASKING ME TO --
THEY ARE HOLDING MY FEET TO
THE FIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ORTHODOXY WINS OUT.
THEY HELD MY FEET TO THE
FIRE UNTIL MY SUSPECT SAID
THAT'S ENOUGH.
THAT'S A TREND?
BIG COMPANIES HAVE BECOME
THE HEAVIES FOR THE CULTURAL
LEFT.
YOU THINK OF BIG COMPANIES
AS CONSERVATIVE ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY ARE THE ONES WHO
SEEM TO BE ENFORCING
ORTHODOXIES, IS THAT MY
IMAGINATION.
MORE OR LESS ENCOURAGING THE
LEFT.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY'RE
OBJECTIVE.
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT
DEBATE.
I THINK THEY WANT US TO
CONFORM CONFORM TO THE
PREVAILING IDEOLOGY THAT'S
OUT THERE.
WHEN THE LEFTIST TAKE YOU
ON, THEY ARE BIG IN NUMBER.
AND PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO SAY
ANYTHING AGAINST THEM.
SO THEY OFTEN WIN.
THEY WON A LITTLE WHILE AGO
TRIED TO GIVE A SPEECH.
THAT WAS ON YOUR SHOW.
>> Tucker: I KNOW.
OR THEY TAKE YOUR JOB AWAY.
HERE IN THE MIDDLE OF WINTER